[Music] I
made you wait like 5 minutes ago.
[Music]
Oh my god, I've given up on skin piano tips.
Yoshino made a mistake, so I know. I heard it
before, so please forget about it and hurry up, even if it's just a minute or a second.
So, what are you planning to do today?
[Music] I
can't think of anything clever. I'm
sorry, but there are no zombies. There are
no zombies. It's
great. I'm sorry, but it's
not a private show. It's
a bit too close, just in case.  I
already knew that there was a seat next to me,
but anyway, this time too
[Music] I'm
not going to ask you to sit next to me even if we're dating.
[Music] I can't really
concentrate because my head is cluttered with the popcorn collection and the
actor's stinky lines.
[Music]
But  You do
n't have to forget, it's
not a lie that I was happy even though I was feeling right now.